MEET KEVIN:
If you’ve ever watched Meet Kevin, you’re
well aware of his infinitely running coupon
codes.
In basically every video, he’ll tell you
that he’s running a massive coupon code
for his programs on building wealth.
And if you wanna take advantage of this coupon
code, you should buy as soon as possible because
the coupon code is expiring momentarily.
But, the reality is that the second that the
current coupon code expires, he’ll have
another one in it’s place.
It’ll probably be for his grandmother’s
birthday or for Leif Erikson day.
At this point, his subscribers have become
well aware of this tactic and it’s pretty
much become a meme.
You can basically go to any of his videos,
and you’ll see a bunch of comments making
fun of his coupon codes.
It’s basically like the boy who cried wolf.
When you constantly have coupon codes running,
no one’s gonna take them seriously.
You might as well just price your product
lower permanently and have no coupon codes
right?
Well, it turns out that there’s actually
some truth behind Kevin’s strategy.
You see, Kevin is by no means the only one
using this strategy.
Likely the biggest culprit is big box retailers.
If you search for Jeans on Kohls for example,
you’ll see that virtually every offering
is 30 to 50% off.
You can see a similar trend with Macy’s,
JCPenny, Dillards, and basically any mall
outlet that you can think of.
It’s not just these normal people stores
that employ this strategy either.
Higher end stores like Hugo Boss are even
more guilty of this.
Take this regular fit suit for example.
Apparently, the original price is $895, but
you can it for 50% off for no reason in the
middle of February.
Must be a Valentines Day sale.
As you can see, the retail industry is full
of this crap whether you look low or high.
And, while it’s easy to write off Kevin
as a flip flopping salesman, writing off these
retailers is not as easy.
Hugo Boss, for example, spent 80 million euros
on marketing within the first quarter of 2022
alone.
So, they know exactly what they’re doing.
They’ve made the conscious decision that
running these infinite sales are worth the
reputational hit that comes along with them.
In fact, one of these retailers even tried
pricing their products more honestly and they’re
revenue ended up going down.
So, here’s why this pesky sales strategy
is so effective and why it’s in Kevin’s
best interest to continue running these coupon
codes despite the public backlash.
THE ORIGIN:
Taking a look back, the origin of modern pricing
startegies can be tracked back to the mid
1800s.
The industrial revolution was in full swing
and cookie cutter department stores were replacing
mom and pop shops across the western world.
Unlike the mom and pop shops, these department
stores carried hundred if not thousands of
different products.
Trying to do the good old barter with each
every customer was not only inefficient but
also unreliable.
After all, one bad cashier could destroy your
profit margins.
So, retailers decided to start implementing
fixed prices across all of their locations.
In our modern, non confrontational world,
this would be seen as a blessing.
You no longer had to haggle with the cashier
everytime you went grocery shopping.
But, back in the day, fixed pricing was seen
in a much more negative light as people felt
that it took away their bargaining power.
Nonetheless, as these department stores became
ubiquitous, fixed pricing became the standard.
At first, this was great for retailers.
They didn’t have to worry about training
staff in marketing and they could pull out
the fairness card against any customer who
wanted a deal.
They could simply say: Sir, if we gave you
a deal, it would be unfair to all of our other
customers, so in good consciences, we can’t
do that.
In reality, a good conscience had nothing
to do with it, but this was a great scapegoat
for dealing with tough customers.
The golden days didn’t last forever though.
While these retailers were able to simply
steam rollover family businesses, they couldn’t
do the same against other retail giants.
They all had massive budgets, marketing campaigns,
and identical pricing.
So, it became extremely difficult to stick
out.
Enter coupons.
If JC Penny couldn’t stick out with their
shopping experience, maybe they could stick
out with their prices.
There was two fatal flaws with this idea though.
First of all, retailers didn’t actually
have very big margins to begin with.
Macy’s, for example, has a net margin of
3-5%.
So, there was no way that they could run the
massive 30 to 50% discounts to get people
in the door.
And even if they could, why should they have
to sell their products for a cheaper price
when Sears across town was charging MSRP.
So, retailers decided, why decrease the sale
price when you could increase the MSRP.
Consumer protection laws meant that they couldn’t
just outright lie or mislead customers about
the MSRP.
So, retailers had to come up with some pretty
clever strategies to cover their butts.
For example, they might offer a pair of jeans
for a $100 in some remote location in Montana.
And now they could advertise in New York that
$50 for those same jeans is 50% off.
This strategy tapped into our inner FOMO and
our deep desire to feel special and exclusive.
And before you knew it, customers were lining
up outside these stores trying to take advantage
of these great one time discounts.
JC PENNY EXPERIMENT:
These constant flash sales did wonders when
it came to getting people in the door, but
people would eventually start to notice right?
And when they did, their opinion of said retailer
would just go down right?
Well, yes and no.
People did begin to notice very quickly actually,
but their reaction wasn’t what you might
expect.
On one side, yes people did become numb to
sales and they started feeling: why don’t
these retailers just put up more honest pricing
to begin with.
But, this numbness led to another, much stronger
feeling as well.
Given that everyone is doing deals all the
time, it’s not worth buying products that
are notorious for this like clothing and kitchen
items for MSRP.
It’s probably just a week or two until that
product goes on sale itself, and they could
just buy it then.
In other words, sales had indeed lost all
meaning, but a lack of a sale very much had
meaning.
A lack of a sale meant that the given price
was a ripoff.
And given that this strategy has been engrained
in our culture for several decades now, all
of us feel this way to a certain a degree.
I mean, it’s no coincidence that black friday
sales have grown to encompass the entirety
of the 4th quarter.
And it’s not random that Amazon suddenly
has two Prime days per year.
The reality is that, though seemingly useless,
these arbitrary discounts drive sales, and
a lack of them drives losses.
And this isn’t just some sort of marketing
theory either.
Ron Johnson’s disastrous reign at JCPenny
has given us real world data.
You’re probably not familiar with Ron himself,
but I’m sure you’re familiar with his
work.
Ron is the architect of the Apple store.
He joined Apple in January of 2000 as Senior
Vice President of retail operations.
And by the time he left, he had propelled
Apple stores to $4,032 per square foot annually.
So, clearly, this guy knew what he was doing,
and that’s why JCPenny would hire him as
CEO in late 2011.
Ron was given that task of transforming JCPenny,
and almost immediately, he was drawn towards
their constant markdowns.
Like most of us, he felt that this was the
21st century.
The internet is a thing.
People can price check on the go.
So, why keep up these braindead list prices.
Well, the answer is seemingly no reason at
all, so Ron went ahead and eliminated all
markdowns across the entire company.
Instead, he introduced “fair and square”
pricing which is exactly what it sounds like.
He also eliminated the use of 99 in price
tags.
Surely, none of us are stupid enough to base
our purchasing decision on these arbitrary
deals or 1 cent right.
If anything, consumers should appreciate the
transparent pricing.
Oh, how wrong he was.
Within just 12 months, same store sales would
decline 25% and the company would end up losing
$1 billion.
Ron’s performance was so bad that it was
literally the worst performance of any retail
CEO ever.
And, this blunder would put JCPenny on the
track towards bankruptcy.
I don’t think you’d be surprised to hear
that Ron would be fired just 4 months later.
So, what went wrong?
THE TAKEAWAY:
The main factor that Ron had failed to consider
was the radically different objectives of
Apple stores and JCPenny outlets.
Here’s the thing, Apple stores don’t need
to sell you on their products.
iPhones sell themselves, and people who go
to Apple stores have usually already made
up their mind.
They’re there to buy or to browse.
There’s not very many people who are on
the fence.
So, the entire point of Apple stores is to
simply create an enjoyable shopping experience.
Meanwhile, JCPenny is trying to sell extraordinarily
oversaturated products in massive upscale
locations.
Shoppers at JCPenny aren’t usually there
with intention.
Many of them are just strolling around the
mall and decided to stop by.
So, JCPenny has to work very hard to get these
strollers to become customers.
The same case could be said about iPhones
as well outside of Apple stores.
If you go into AT&T, Verizon, or TMobile,
you’ll see dozens of deals, trade in discounts,
and of course aggressive salesmen.
Selling YouTube courses is much closer to
JCPenny than it is to Apple.
People are watching YouTube videos in their
leisure time.
They just want to be entertained and maybe
informed.
But, they’re definitely not jumping up and
down about the prospect of buying a $1,700
course.
We should also mention that basically every
finance YouTuber has their own money course
and their own YouTube course.
So, Kevin not only has to coninvce a casual
viewer to buy an expensive product, but he
also has to convince them to buy his product
over someone elses.
Enter coupon codes.
Offering a quote on quote $1700 course for
$500 accomplishes two things.
First of all, it creates a sense of urgency.
People who watch Kevin regularly know that
another coupon is just around the corner,
but new viewers will naturally feel that they
have a limited time to take advantage of this
opportunity.
We should also mention that out of his regular
viewers, the people who are willing to buy
his course have probably already bought it.
So, a coupon code or a lack of a coupon code
wouldn’t really sway his regular viewers,
but it does wonders with new viewers.
Aside from creating urgency, the listing price
also creates a high price anchor.
If you were judging the course based on just
it’s content, you might feel that it’s
only worth $50.
But, since you’re given this initial price
of $1700, $500 seems a lot more reasonable.
Even if you were looking for a more aggressive
deal, you’d likely be aiming for $400 or
$300, not $50.
And let’s just say, this strategy has worked
extraordinarily well for Kevin.
THE AFTERMATH:
You can argue all you want about marketing
strategies and brand perception, but something
you can’t argue with is results, and Kevin’s
got the best results in the space period.
Graham Stephan for example is the largest
finance YouTuber with over 4 million subscribers.
And in 2021, he made $6.1 million which is
an extraordinary amount of money.
Meet Kevin, however, has less than half of
Graham’s subscriber count, yet he was making
$3 million per month in 2021.
Not to mention he now owns a private jet.
Now, let me be clear, this is not an endorsement
of Meet Kevin or his courses.
Rather, it’s simply a discussion about how
effective his coupon code strategy is despite
the fact that he’s always offering them.
The bottom line is that while annoying, it’s
effective, and the only thing we can blame
is our own psychology.
At the end of the day, Kevin is just using
the psychology of money to sell a course about
the psychology of money.
Along those lines, I have a question for you.
Would you buy jeans that aren’t on sale?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you would like to help
my psychology.
And of course, consider checking out our discord
community to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.